shukrali is a livestock farmer who lost
his home in the floods he and his family
have been living on the side of this
road for almost a week now without any
kind of help
go and see the condition of our home
what is the point of talking about it it
is only allah who can provide he is the
one who gives and who takes away
sweetie beckham is waiting for
government assistance on the outskirts
of the city of silet after queuing for
hours she is beginning to lose hope
there is water all around my home chest
deep we've been sitting here waiting for
relief for hours and so far we've
received nothing
armed forces have rescued or evacuated
more than hundred thousand people from
two of the worst hit districts in the
northeast many others are still stranded
in remote rural areas
this is one of the many school in sunam
gandhian silit region that has been used
as makeshift shelter for those villagers
were affected by the flood most of the
people took shelter on their own now
they're in desperate need for food and
fresh water
even residents in urban areas with
better drainage systems are affected
we've never seen floods like this in our
lifetime our home has water up to the
hip with no running water and
electricity we're now using rain water
use
packaging during her visit to the area
prime minister sheikh hasina said future
building developments should take into
account the number of natural disasters
that bangladesh experiences
many of these people are still
recovering from the last month's
pre-monsoon flash floods
we left our home to take shelter here
there's no food or fresh water it would
help if we got some relief from the
government so we can get by
for the poor rural farmers who have lost
everything it'll take months if not
years to rebuild their homes they need
all the assistance they can get but help
is yet to come tanvi choudhry al-jazeera
silhouette northeast bangladesh